All-pairs N-body is an N squared algorithm.
Each object must compute its interaction with each other object,
So each N object has to compute N minus 1 forces.
N objects times N minus 1 force computations per object yields work proportional to N squared.
Now, there's a way you can approximate N-body computations with high accuracy with superior work efficiency.
There are tree-based algorithms, for example.
One's called Barnes Hut, that has N log N complexity and a method called
fast multi-pole that's actually linear order of N complexity.
They basically work by lumping distant bodies together and treating them as a single body during the calculation.
These are neat algorithms; fast multi-pole was actually named one of the top 10 algorithms of the 20th century,
but they're also considerably more complex.
All-pairs, on the other hand, is very simple and often the way that
production N-Body algorithms compute forces among close together objects,
and with it, we're going to show how to use the memory hierarchy in an efficient way
to make this computation as fast as possible.